foreign
good evening members and uh welcome uh
to this meeting of the 20th of October
um at seven o'clock it's cabinet meeting
uh fire alarm procedures if the fire
alarm is activated vacate the offices
via the stairs please do not use the
lifts
assembling holy Square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
C restriction on use of mobile phones
please switch off or turn to silence
your mobile phones and do not make or
receive calls whilst this meeting is in
progress
um
please note that this meeting has been
live streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will be subsequently broadcast on the
internet
um does anyone intend to film the
meeting
no I couldn't couldn't see any hands
um
we'll then skip
uh
um the following members have asked to
speak under Council procedure rule 20.1
for item four I have councilor Whitehead
out of item five uh Council Auburn item
six councilor White's head and item
seven Council Whitehead are there any
more members who request to speak
no okay
uh gender item one uh are there any
apologies for absence
apart from the leader but thank you
Charles yes uh councilor Ashby Ashby has
sent her apologies uh for the meeting uh
item number two Declarations of interest
does anyone have an interest to declare
in the items of business on the agenda
this evening
no brilliant
gender item three minutes of the
previous meeting to approve the summary
of recommendations and decisions of the
cabinet meeting held on the 22nd of
September 2022. the copies attached to
the agenda pack I propose that we
approve the minutes uh do I have a
second there
councilor Bob bayford do members agree
brilliant agenda item four Westgate on C
neighborhood plan regulation 16
consultation and a formal response from
planet District Council as councilor
Ashby is unable to be here I will
introduce this instead
a draft neighborhood plan is being
prepared for Westgate and by the
neighborhood plan group and Town Council
as part of its statutory role in this
process this council is currently
running a public consultation known as
regulation 16. on the west gate
neighborhood plan which finishes next
Tuesday the 27th of October this is the
last chance for comments to be made on
the draft Plan before it is examined by
the independent Examiner a significant
level of work has gone into prepare in
the draft neighborhood plan over a
number of years and it is generally to
be supported however there are some
areas of concern and these are set out
in section 2 and Annex one of the report
the main policy issues of concern relate
to some of the proposed local green
spaces and Countryside triangle
once all the comments have been reviewed
received an examination into the draft
plan will be undertaken by an
independent examiner The Examiner will
consider all the comments made in
relation to the draft neighborhood plan
and make recommendations as to any
changes they consider are needed to meet
government guidance officers in the
process offices are in the process of
appointing The Examiner which is done in
conjunction with the Town Council and
therefore I move the recommendation
to speak under 20.1 I believe we have uh
councilor Whitehead
thank you chair
I'd like to fully support the inclusion
of the biodiversity Net game requirement
but would also like to ask for further
specifics relating to the functional
green corridor I appreciate fully that
we are limited by the requirements of
the inspectors however Green Space being
crucial to the long-term sustainability
of biodiversity I was wondering if it
would be possible to discuss further if
we believe there is anything that we can
realistically do to provide for this
space while still addressing inspectors
concerns thank you
thank you councilor Whitehead as I'm
just standing in for councilor Ashby and
I'm sure you could appreciate that I
don't have an answer that but I will
refer to our officer Adrian who may be
able to offer assistance
uh yeah the uh there was a very specific
proposal that we had originally put in
the local plan for a corridor between
the old the existing housing and the new
housing the inspector took the
um that that was a matter for the
detailed design so the Strategic policy
in the local plan requires a certain
amount of open space I think it's about
11 hectares but it's the disposition of
that space
within the site that's a matter for the
planning application so there will be
open space quite a lot of open space but
not necessarily in that specific
location
thank you
uh therefore I um move this motion uh do
I have a secondary
councilor George cupp do members agree
thank you very much moving on to agenda
item five
Environmental Protection enforcement
policy to introduce councilor Jill
bayford
assisting enforcement policy used by the
Environmental Protection team has been
updated to ensure compliance with
current legislation and guidance
in particular the updated policy
reflects the use of community protection
warning CPW and Community protection
notice CPN
anti-social Behavior Powers alongside
existing statutory legislation used by
Environmental Protection officers in
relation to nuisance complaints
then it District Council has signed up
to the enforcement Concord confirming
its commitment to the principles of good
enforcement
this policy encompasses the principles
of this concordant
the policy lays out how enforcement
action is decided upon and provides both
those raising Environmental Protection
complaints or those causing them to
understand what action is available to
the local authority to resolve these
issues
the policy lays out how we investigate
complaints including priority of cases
the general General policy relates to
all enforcement actions and describes
the basic principles of enforcement
guidance is provided on what is
considered when making a decision on
enforcement action
the policy then goes on to lay out the
various types of enforcement action
available to the local Authority
the policy includes details on
complaints and appeals available to
those who are affected by enforcement
decisions made by the local Authority
Council priorities for growth
environment and communities have also
been considered within the policy
the policy will be accessible on the
council's website
I would like to recommend that cabinet
approved the updated Environmental
Protection enforcement policy which is
annex one
thank you councilor bayford to speak
under 20.1 I have Council Auburn
yes thank you chair
um
fully support this policy
it's always good to review policy after
so long and to ensure that your policy
is updated we've alleged with the proper
legislation
etc etc having read through it all that
they're
maybe I'm old-fashioned I suppose but um
it just the phrase that I haven't seen
in it and I just think uh that maybe uh
to ask to consider it being included and
that is when looking to take any action
uh enforcement action
to also consider whether that action is
in the public interest that's not in a
report at all and and I would ask
um to ensure the safety of the policy
and to give the officers uh the
the chance to see whether those
decisions that they're taking is it in
the public interest to service and not
just to say they've done this wrong or
Serbia because there could be other
complicated issues because nothing's
black and white in in the enforcement
game as I as I know so um I would ask
chair that uh that that could be taken
into consideration thank you
thank you councilor Auburn uh councilor
bayford do you have anything to come
back on
thank you
yes I'm sure that that is taken into
consideration uh maybe I could just
defer to
to confirm that thank you
yeah absolutely it's part of the
enforcement Concordia and so we'll
explicitly put it in there as a line to
make sure it's really obvious
ly thank you chair
brilliant thank you
um therefore councilor bayford has moved
the recommendation uh do I have a
secondary
councilor Bob bayford the recommendation
is members are requested to approve
Dentistry council's Environmental
Protection enforcement policy for 2022
to 2027 do members agree
brilliant thank you gender item six
tenant and leaseholder services annual
reports to introduce councilor Jill
bayford
Ginger
Regulatory Compliance a social landlord
must provide timely and relevant
information that enables tenants to
scrutinize their landlord's performance
and such provision must include the
publication of an annual report
to ensure compliance the tenant
leaseholder Services provides quarterly
performance reports that are scrutinized
by involved tenants and leaseholders and
are available to view on the council's
website
they have now written their first annual
report for the Year
2021-22 this being the first full
Financial year the service has been
managed by the council since its
transition in October 2020 and it is
ready for publication
the report gives details on the key
performance indicators for the year
which is supported with case studies and
engaging photos
if approved the TLs will ensure the
report is accessible by making available
on the council's website and throughout
a web reader the web page will include
an equality statement and invites
interested parties to request a printed
document or in another format and hard
copies will be taped sorry to request a
printed document in another format and
hard copies will be taken to community
events for interested parties to take
away
I move the recommendation to publish the
annual report on the council's website
thank you councilor payford to speak
under 20.1 I have councilor Whitehead
thank you chair and thank you councilor
bayford
firstly I would like to say that this is
well presented clear and coherent report
and I think it's especially positive
having the forward statements from our
head of housing portfolio holder and the
chair of our tenant and leaseholder
group as it makes the status of the
in-house hair Service as a collaborative
and inclusive effort very clear
the 93.3 satisfaction rating for mirrors
is positive as is the improving
relationship what is also positive is
that we are exceeding our Target for
voids with minor works but there is a
significant disparity in the opposite
direction for voids requiring major
works with a target of 22.5 days but an
actual let time of 65.43 days
I just wanted to ask if this is due to
particularly complex voids or whether
there are other factors influencing the
disparity that we can look to work on as
turnover is especially important at this
time
the compliance figures are hugely
encouraging and exactly what I'd hoped
for post Eastern housing and I know the
amount of work that it's taken to bring
us to this point and would like to
publicly recognize everyone who has
worked so hard to bring this about thank
you
thank you councilor Whitehead councilor
bayford do you have a response thank you
councilor Whitehead for your support
um
but I think I'll perhaps asked
what portal if you could explain the
reasons for the major works okay thank
you
actually Sally's going to work oh sorry
okay
thank you for the question
um yes Council Whitehead you're
absolutely correct we have been getting
a higher volume of complex voids which
are requiring major work some of the
properties requiring full research
refurbishments
um this is not just a phenomenon say the
word sorry phenomenon that is being
experienced by thanet through our
networking groups that we are members of
we found that other areas in the UK are
also experiencing the same thing
thank you
thank you very much uh councilor Bob
base would you have a question yeah I'm
just following that answer I just wonder
um presumably
um these are properties that have been
really badly treated by tenants
um is there any way that uh these people
can buy be identified earlier before the
properties reached a terrible state
where they do require such radical
refurbishment
foreign
thank you
um
I the yes and no is the answer to that
um in in some cases
um we find that the properties are in
need of such refurbishment because they
have been inhabited by a single family
or a single tenant for many many decades
um and often those families perhaps
don't want Council intervention and by
the time we get the properties back
um they've because they've not wanted us
to refurbish their kitchen or their
bathroom and that obviously is their
prerogative as long as there's not a
health and safety issue all of those
items are required at that stage and we
do get quite a few properties back like
that you're absolutely correct and we
are trying to tackle
um uh residents that are mistreating
their property before it gets to that
stage and by doing that we are doing
that by getting our housing officers to
carry out tenancy audits now so each
year 20 of our properties that we
wouldn't usually get access to people
that don't access our service we are
looking to be able to go into their
property and have a look around and see
if there are any repair or tenancy
requirements
thank you
thank you uh so councilor Jill bayford
has moved the recommendation do I have a
secondary
councilor David Saunders and the
recommendations
is that cabinet is asked to authorize
the following to publish the tenant and
Lease Services annual report to the
council's website do members agree
agenda item seven tenants and
leaseholder services procurement uh
kitchen bathroom and lifts refurbishment
to introduce councilor Jill payford
first item in this report ask cabinet to
agree to the letting of a contract to
refurbish the lifts in a Victor house in
Margate
the value of this contract will be about
315 000 and we will be to refurbish the
two passenger lifts that service the
residents in Victor house
Invicta house is a 15-story high-rise
recently both lifts have been plagued
with breakdowns this causes much
inconvenience to the residents
especially for those who cannot leave
their floor without an operational lift
due to disabilities
high frequency of breakdowns and
increase and also Inc also increases the
risk of entrapment which can be a scare
experience for the person that becomes
trapped in a broken down lift
the lifts currently need 70 000 pounds
worth of replacement components but as
they are coming to the end of their life
cycle the TLs feels it would make more
economical economical sense to carry out
a full refurbishment
the second item in this report asked
cabinet to agree to the letting of a new
contract that will continue the
council's kitchen and bathroom
refurbishment program
sadly the contractor that was carrying
out this program went into
Administration early this year and this
has meant the TLs need to procure a new
contract ahead of the specific time
specified time sorry the TLs proposes to
let the contract for five years with an
option to extend for a further 24 months
the total value for this contract is
three million 337 375
000 pounds
I move the recommendation set out in the
report
thank you councilor bayford to speak
under 20.1 I have councilor Whitehead
thank you againcha
I'm fully in support of the suggested
option of a full lift refurbishment to
the Victor house rather than simply
repairs as it's not only the right
choice for residents but also the right
choice economically considering the
number of repairs required and the age
of the lifts
in relation to both contracts something
that I asked to be looked at when I held
the housing portfolio was addressing the
way we look at contracts within housing
in order to attempt to increase and
build the local economy as part of the
contracts we control
currently we use the most economically
advantageous tender model which at a
basic level is the cheapest
there are immediate economic advantages
to this that considering the size of
these contracts and the importance of
building our local economy I suggested
that we look Instead at increasing the
weighting of other factors within our
tendering process such as inclusion of
local jobs or apprenticeships and
elements that provide a community good
as well as a Local Economic stimulus
councilor bayford and Mr Paul Porter and
I discussed that in relation to the
contracts listed at our last briefing
I can see that they are still listed
under most economically advantageous
tender approach that considering the
importance of this and the positives for
our local economy that looking at how we
use and apply our tendering weighting
could bring can we commit to looking
into this fully for our future contracts
thank you
thank you Council Whitehead councilor
Jill bayford
thank you to council Whitehead for the
question yes as you say we discussed
this
um my understanding is we cannot uh
specifically ask that local companies uh
are in are involved but that we can make
recommendations
um such as the inclusion of
apprenticeships and the likes
um which I think would would be very
advantageous for
um local young people or local people
together
um perhaps you'd like to enlarge on this
thank you councilor bayford
um well obviously the first issue here
is that we need to comply fully with
procurement legislation and ensure that
our contracts are met in accordance with
the council's contract study orders but
there is provision within that to
consider
um social value in the in the um
evaluation of tenders at that stage in
the process and
we do look to do that wherever we
possibly can so obviously for larger
term contracts we can as councilman said
look to include local apprenticeships we
can include a local office provision if
we want to or
you know we can encourage the use of
local work subcontractors as well within
Provisions the exact split of the um the
cost and and quality evaluations in any
tender doesn't have to be
um cost first and you know for example
and Sal is quickly writing down numbers
for me
um we could um you know have a split
that gives a extra weighting to the
quality of the submission uh over the
price so it isn't necessarily the
cheapest and actually often we wouldn't
want the cheapest tender we want the
best tender for the in terms of service
delivery and added value for the local
community so so absolutely we can look
to include local social value wherever
that's possible
thank you very much
thank you uh councilor bayford has moved
the motion and
do I have a second
councilor Bob bayford to members agree
thank you very much that concludes the
business for tonight's meeting I declare
this meeting closed at 7 22 p.m the live
stream of this meeting will now end
thank you